هناك لقط ميسون حتى الان يعني حتى الوكاله
الرسميه في لبنان ذكرت ان هناك كان رد
مدفعي اسرائيلي ولكن بالفعل لم يكن هناك
رد
مدفعي الترجيحات تقول بانه عندما القبه
الحديديه اعترضت بعض الصواريخ سقطت بعض
الصواريخ في مناطق مفتوحه في لبنان البعض
فسرها على انها رد مدفع اسرائيلي ولكن في
الحقيقه لم يكن هناك اي رد مدفعي الجيش
اللبناني حتى الان لم يصدر اي بيان اسراء
اي بيان رسمي ليحدد المنطقه ليحدد عدد
الصواريخ وما ان كان هناك رد ولكن بالفعل
يعني بمجرد بان يكون الجيش اللبناني قد
يعني نفى موضوع الرد كانت كان هذا هو
التفسير خاصه وانه يعني البعض تحدث عن
سكان الجنوب كانوا قد تحدثوا عن سقوط
صواريخ يبدو انها الصواريخ التي كان هناك
اعتراض لها من ااا من القبه من القبه
الحديديه